sometimes filmmakers hide obscure in
jokes so subtly that it takes a few
viewings to spot them if you're able to
spot them at all these hidden gags might
just make you want to watch these flicks
all over again Shaun of the Dead spoiler
epic beginning the zombie horror comedy
Shaun of the Dead opened the Cornetto
trilogy with a hilarious look at how a
British slacker and his pub loving
friends handled the zombie apocalypse
but if that lovable loser Shaun could
speak Hindi he might have been clued in
to the impending zombie apocalypse when
he went to the convenience store I about
15k the radio broadcast in the store
actually reveals that the dead are
coming back to life and attacking people
a joke is so well-hidden it's a
privately buried treasure niteowl saves
the wings the opening sequence of
Watchmen has a pretty awesome reference
to a famous caped crusader check the
frame featuring night owl punching a
masked gunman outside of an opera house
the Gotham Opera House yes it's Batman's
origin in the background is a rich
couple clearly meant to be Bruce Wayne's
parents Thomas and Martha the Opera
bills Reedy fledermaus German for at the
bat and just to make the joke a little
more obvious several posters advertise
the first issue of the Batman comic book
on the wall as well holy Easter eggs
Batman Sherman and Peabody there's a
subtle reference to other Time
Traveler's impact the future but you
wouldn't get the joke unless you stayed
in the theater when Marty travels to
1955 he crashes the DeLorean into the
Peabody's family barn the members of the
Peabody family poked their heads into
the barn at which point that little boy
claims that Marty's time machine is
actually a UFO
if you arch through the credits you'll
see that the boy's name is Sherman
Sherman Peabody our reference to the
cartoon Time Traveller's mr. Peabody and
Sherman
unlike a DeLorean crashing into the barn
that joke flew right over most viewers
hats Lord Farquaad even though he's in a
movie for kids
Lord Farquaad from Shrek was given that
name to get a laugh out of the adults if
you didn't catch the joke here's a hint
try saying his name over and over I am
Lord Farquaad
Farquaad Farquaad Farquaad that's right
he's a complete quod imagine how disney
chief Michael Eisner felt considering
the villain was reportedly based on him
the despicable Lehman Brothers while the
financial crisis of 2008 wasn't funny
the creators of Despicable Me thought a
joke about it wouldn't hurt if you had
eagle eyes you probably noticed that
when GRU enters the bank of evil to get
a loan there's a small sign that raves
formerly Lehman Brothers a jab at the
global financial services firm that went
bankrupt and filed for chapter 11 in
2008 Kevin Smith's jaws references
director Kevin Smith is a film buff and
he likes to show it one proof he sneaks
a boatload of Jaws references into his
films like the clerks salsa shark and
Mallrats characters birdie Bruce and Tia
squint and chasing Amy's Hoover ex even
takes it a step further in chasing Amy
with an homage to the scene where jaws
characters compared scars the twist
instead of showing battle wounds banky
and alyssa compare scars they received
while romancing the ladies I need a
bigger potion
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
which obscure movie jokes you think
should have made the list